[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mal nommé
les choses c'est ajouté au malheur du
monde disait Albert
Camu nous sommes la France héritière des
philosophes de la Révolution française
et de la déclaration des droit de
l'homme du Conseil National de la
Résistance de Léon Blom et du général de
GA nous sommes le pays porteur de la
liberté de la tolérance de
l'universalité
ça veut dire madame la Première ministre
que nous avons une responsabilité
imminente nous ne pouvons pas faire
pardon madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères des déclarations uniquement
type K d'oré surfiche ou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas nous sommes là pour dire simplement
l'empathie n'est pas exclusive de
l'action politique nous n sommes là pour
vous dire qu'il faut utiliser les mots
crime contre l'humanité c'est la réalité
ce mot cette expression utilisezla
faites-la utiliser par l'Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le minimum
la légitime défense de l'État d'Israël
c'est un droit permanent quand vous
recevez des milliers de de missiles et
que vous assistez à ce qui s'est passé
dans les kibut légitime défense c'est le
minimum et faites en sorte madame la
Première ministre que celles et ceux qui
dans la République trahissent les
valeurs de la République trahissent les
valeurs de la nation en ne soutenant pas
l'état d'Israël et en faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme faites en sorte qu'il soit
sévèrement
puni
est à Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères madame Colona
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur carucci je ne voudrais pas en
venir à penser que vous n'avez pas bien
entendu le président de la République
Monsieur le Sénateur madame la Première
ministre je n'ai pas je n'ai pas imaginé
que vous fassiez attention à mes propos
madame la Première ministre vient de
rappeler toute l'horreur que nous
inspirent les actes barbares qui ont été
commis par le Hamas et de dire de redire
la condamnation absolue par la France de
ces actes terroristes commis par un
groupe terroriste le Hamas soutenu par
d'autres groupes terroristes et de plus
les prises de Tage abjectent les
assassinat monstrueux les massacres ne
laissent aucun doute sur la nature
terroriste du Hamas notre condamnation
est donc totale et absolue et ceci
depuis le premier jour Monsieur le
Sénateur face à l'horreur nous sommes
solidaires d'Israël et du peuple
israélien et nous disons avec force
qu'Israël a le droit de se défendre nous
l'avons dit publiquement depuis le
premier jour nous le redisons nous le
disons à tous nos interlocuteurs dans la
région et ailleurs et dans le même temps
oui la première ministre le disait la
responsabilité diplomatique de la France
est aussi d'éviter l'embrasement dans la
région l'Autorité palestinienne a un
rôle à jouer à cet égard nous continuons
sououtenir le président de la République
s'est exprimé sur ce point très
clairement hier la diplomatie française
est aussi active pour que la situation
ne s'aggrave pas à la frontière avec le
Liban je ne doute pas que vous suiviez
avec attention ce qui s'y passe comme à
la frontière avec la Syrie le président
de la République et moi-même avons
multiplié les contacts depuis samedi
avec nos homologues israélien
palestinien dans la région européen et
bien au-delà et bien sûr comme l'a dit
madame la Première ministre quand le
calme sera revenu il faudra se demander
comment mieux prendre en compte les
aspirations du peuple palestinien
comment mieux répondre au droit absolu
d'Israël à la sécurité la paix doit
rester notre impératif même si
d'évidence ce moment n'est pas
venu monsieur
[Applaudissements]
kucci
[Musique]